[Musique]
une grand jury rtl le figaro lci invitée
aujourd'hui christian jacob président
des républicains et député de
seine-et-marne
le débat dirigé par benjamin sport
touche bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce
grand jury bonjour christian jacob
bonjour merci d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui en direct du grand studio
rtl
avec toutes les précautions nécessaires
bien sûr dans le cadre de cette crise
sanitaire est à mes côtés aujourd'hui
pour vous interroger guillaume roquette
du figaro bonjour guillaume et adrien
gendre de lci bonjour adrien enfin vous
pouvez toujours réagir en direct bien
sûr pendant cette émission sur les
réseaux sociaux hashtag le grand jury et
toutes vos questions seront posées à la
fin de cette émission par marie-pierre à
date de la rédaction numérique de rt
alors christian jacob vous êtes à la
tête de la première force d'opposition
au parlement vous-même avait été victime
du coronavirus et vous en être établie
on y reviendra dans cette émission au
début de la crise vous avez voté les
textes d'urgence sanitaire et économique
proposé par le gouvernement
mais cette union sacrée réclamée par le
président a fait long feu
très vite les républicains que vous
présidez ont critiqué le manque
d'anticipation de l'exécutif sur les
masques notamment
mais n'avez-vous pas aussi votre part de
responsabilité du temps où vous étiez au
pouvoir entre 2007 et 2012 sous nicolas
sarkozy la pression budgétaire notamment
avec la tarification à l'activité a dit
ont déstabilisé l'hôpital public
aujourd'hui au contraire vous réclamez
un grand plan d'investissement dans nos
établissements de santé et même une
augmentation importante du personnel
soignant sur cinq ans des propositions
qui figurent parmi les 50 mesures que
les députés les républicains viennent de
lancer de mettre sur la table dans le
cadre du plan de déconfinement et au
delà et là aussi la question et la
rigueur budgétaire que pendant très
longtemps vous avez défendues at elle
trouvé ses limites surtout cela nous
reviendrons dans le cette émission
langue membres et nous commençons bien
sûr par les travaux pratiques de ceux
des confinement qui sera annoncée par le
premier ministre à l'assemblée nationale
mardi
la première question vous est posée par
guillaume ok oui il annoncera les
modalités concrètes du déconfinement
mais la date on la connaît c'est le 11
mai est-ce que ça va vous paraître le la
bonne échéance ou est-ce que c'est trop
tard dit
écoutez il fallait fixer une date parce
que je crois qu'il est important que le
calendrier soit se reposer ça permet
tout d'abord de s'y préparer
ça permet aux entreprises d'anticiper
j'espère aussi que le gouvernement
le gouvernement lance n'anticipe ce que
l'on voit dans cette crise c'est qu'il
ya trois éléments d'abord aller
sanitaires et donc l'urgence absolue
c'est de trouver les réponses sanitaire
c'est pour ça que nous avons pris ou des
positions pour le fait qu' une
possibilité de tester à plus grande
échelle possible de se protéger avec les
masques etc
donc c'est ça le premier enjeu ensuite
elle est économique c'est-à-dire que
plus vite nous aurons les réponses
sanitaires plus vite on peut redémarrer
l'économie et plus vite on redémarre à
l'économie - le choc social sera
important parce qu'il y aura les trois
niveaux sanitaire économique et social
dans cette crise donc le fait d'avoir
acté une date je crois est une bonne
chose
on va détailler tous ces thèmes dans un
instant juste sur la forme à jeanne haag
illusion le premier ministre a
finalement présenté son plan de
déconfinement devant la représentation
nationale à l'assemblée
d'abord puis au sénat est ce que vous
vous dites satisfecit on est associés on
est considérés et c'est la bonne manière
de procéder
on est associés il s'agit d'être
spectateur non je sais pas
la manière dont les choses vont se
dérouler ce qu'il est
ce qui est clair c'est que si à l'issue
on voit un vote pardon à l'issue on ne
va pas on va pas voter sur un sur un
discours soit ils s'invitent sur une
déclaration en l'occurrence oui moi je
souhaite qu'il puisse y avoir un texte
et qui puisse y avoir un vrai travail
parlementaire il est à dire nous avons
vous allez vous abstenir avant juste nos
rangs de discuter un an que vous allez
venez on annonce que je ce qu'une
chouette moi c'est qu'il y ait un vrai
débat au parlement un débat digne de ce
nom c'est à dire avec une proposition
c'est énorme
l'enjeu de cette discussion sur le
déconfinement seller réponse sanitaire
que l'on apporte à la crise le plan de
relance économique non une partie
d'ailleurs été votée avec la loi de
finances et puis le choc social qui
s'ensuit donc ça n'est pas anecdotique
est heureux que vous ne le voteriez par
des clans de déconfinement christian
jacob
on a besoin vous rêvez d'un vote on va
pas un discours c'est pas c'est pas le
grand oral on le fait boire des litres
de pluie par exemple
oui mais là en l'occurrence moi ce que
je souhaite c'est qu'il y ait un vrai
débat avec des propositions de la roupie
parlementaire un travail en commissions
et on peut le faire dans des délais
d'ailleurs c'est quoi un travail en
commission avant mardi
après alice eu la manière dont ça se
passe normalement au présente un texte
étrange lui s'il ya un débat en
commission et et on vote à une bonne
chose qu'il y ait un vote sur le
discours de mardi si on vous écoute mais
c'est trop c'est à dire on a fait preuve
tout le monde s'accorde à le dire à la
fois de responsabilité mais surtout
d'être force de proposition et c'est ce
que nous faisons ce que le groupe de
l'assemblée vient de faire à
l'initiative de crédit tout juste est ce
que vous trouvez que c'est trop tôt est
ce que nombre c'est que x men 4 octobre
salle où marie julie baup qui les
voyaient loiret à l'issue du discours du
premier ministre il doit y avoir un
débat en commission évaluer les mesures
alors on a le droit d'avoir un avis
peut-être les améliorer et concrète des
temps reprocher quelques juillet et
ensuite on votera vous le disiez vos
députés
les députés de votre du groupe et leur
ont fait des propositions concrètes
notamment une nouvelle ouverture plus
rapide des cafés des restaurants parce
que c'est prévu jusqu'à présent en juin
et vous dis donc ouvrir plus tôt dans
les zones où l'épidémie a a été peu
présente en prenant compte en rencontres
les territoires c'est ça notre notre
proposition parce que voyez il ya par
exemple départements du cantal à ma
connaissance rien d'un seul clan je
crois pas qu'ils aient eu un seul cas
donc on voit bien qu'il ya la nécessité
d'avoir ce tandem entre le représentant
de l'état doit être le préfet et ça veut
dire aussi qu'il faut renforcer le rôle
des préfets par rapport aux autres
administrations déconcentrées de façon à
ce que les collectivités territoriales
n'est qu'un interlocuteur et passent pas
leur temps à faire le tour des
différentes des différentes
administrations
ensuite en respectant un cahier des
charges
d'ailleurs auquel se sont préparés les
cafés hôtels restaurants leurs
fédérations de voir si
l'écartement entre les tables doit être
d'un mètre avait accordé aux deux mètres
les mesures barrières par département il
faut prendre en compte la réalité de la
réalité des territoires et on sait bien
que la situation est différente dans un
département comme le cantal où il ya eu
aucun cas à ce stade je sais pas comment
les choses vont évoluer
mais aujourd'hui il n'y en a pas eu et
un département comme le le haut rhin qui
admet qui a été pris doit décider qui
doit d c'est ce que c'est le préfet qui
doit dire dans mon département il ya eu
moins de 4 donc on peut ouvrir est ce
que c'est ça que vous nous dites
concrètement avec l'école avec les
collectivités territoriales il est très
important de lier ou alors on y viendra
sans doute sur sur l'école on ne peut
pas prendre des décisions sans y
associer les maires ou les présidents de
départ ou présidents de départements
donc le gouvernement a raison quand il
dit c'est le couple préfets maires qui
va présider ce déconfinement elle fait
des cdd s'il va pas décider de tout il
ya des règles il ya des règles
nationales mais c'est pour ça qu'on peut
pas voter sur un discours et voyez bien
que tout soit raté j nationale et mairie
en locaux méritent d'être travaillée et
et encore une fois on peut le faire dans
des délais assez contraint ça n'est pas
une difficulté à vraisemblable de mon
point de vue qu'en est il des
déplacements interrégionaux est-ce qu'il
faut les permettre ou pas christian
jacob
selon vous à partir du moment où des
consignes on va pas établir des
frontières au sein d'eads et des régions
des départements ou ou des villes on
sait bien que l'encadrement et encore
une fois c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'on a besoin d'avoir un vrai travail
de fond sur la proposition de sortie du
mouvement quand on sort du confinement
et c'est essentiel un moment d'en sortir
on sait qu'il faut anticiper le fait
qu'il peut y avoir une deuxième vague et
ben justement jeunes et pour ça on parle
des dépassements interdits parce que la
preuve des vacances russe a tellement je
voulais vous dire je précisais
saint-jacques héroïne aux auditeurs et
téléspectateurs comprennent bien il ya
des élus dont des députés a l'air comme
gênés anvers philippe gosselin qui
propose de décaler les vacances d'été
grosso modo de 15 jours de les faire de
mi juillet à mi septembre pour permettre
aux enfants de reprendre plus tard et
aux français justement de profiter d'un
bout d'été pour protéger cette économie
touristique restauration etc dont on
parlait à l'instant
vous partagez vous cette position je
pense que c'est très compliqué là pour
le coup
c'est compliqué pour les rentrées
scolaires
parce que comment on cale la rentrée
scolaire derrière derrière tout cela
donc moi je jeu réd pas forcément
d'accord avec ses deux ailes et pas dans
les 50 propositions d'ailleurs non c'est
non mais bien sûr n'a changé on est un
moment où il ya tout l'intérêt d'avoir
une discussion
nous l'avons fait au moment de la loi de
finances rectificative un certain nombre
de propositions ont été d'ailleurs
repris par le gouvernement la
l'abaissement de sur la diminution du
chiffre d'affaires liée liés aux
qu'ovide lorsqu'une entreprise
il fallait pour bénéficier du net qui
est une baisse de 70% du chiffre
d'affaires nous l'avons ramené à 50%
c'est une initiative qui a été prise par
les députés les républicains
l'abaissement de la tva sur les masques
c'est une initiative des députés les
républicains l'annulation des charges
pour les tpe
c'est une initiative des députés il ya
un public est indicative et il ya
beaucoup et qui on arrive dans tous les
sens non c'était un débat sur la loi de
finances oui qui était actif par exemple
guillaume pelletier propose ce matin
toujours dans le cadre des vacances
scolaires puisqu'on en parle guillaume
pelletier votre numéro 2 valent un
nouveau numéro deux il veut diviser le
prix des autoroutes par deux pendant
l'été mais ça vous aide mais cette
proposition c'est pas nouveau de la part
de guillaume pelletier sur les
autoroutes
il met cette proposition sur la table et
c'est bien mais c'est pour ça que oui on
peut pas on a besoin d'avoir ce débat
est encore une fois à l'assemblée on
sait fonctionner et vous êtes bien dans
ton style qu'est ce que lewis est cette
proposition je pense que c'est une
proposition qui mérite tout à fait
déposer sur le débat parce que si on
veut effectivement que la destination
france soit favoriser au maximum bien il
faut permettre aux français dans les
meilleures conditions de pouvoir prendre
des vacances à un moment où il va avoir
une de leurs pieds dit attention si vous
regrettez pas les prix impôt
exceptionnel ça je suis moins favorable
d'une manière générale puis pas
favorable du prévôt râblât la peau et à
l'augmentation des jeux pan soyez pour
reprendre ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure
si la dépense publique était un gage
d'efficacité ça se saurait la france est
championne du monde la dépense publique
et quand on compare nos résultats
notamment dans l'hôpital ou ailleurs
avec par exemple les résultats en
allemagne
on voit bien que le c'est pas plus aux
dépens turna dépenses publiques plus en
efficaces en va y revenir c'est ce que
va pouvoir bien souvent le contraire est
encore une caisse non regarde pas besoin
d'impôts en plus ça c'est très clair
encore une question sur les vacances
pour les français qui voudraient partir
en italie ou en espagne
est ce que pour vous il faut ou non
laisser des frontières entre les pays
européens
il faut laisser les frontières bien
évidemment il est l'aîné fermée pourrait
il faut il faut contrôler les fermes et
moi je suis pas favorable à la fermeture
absolue d'aider des frontières mais je
pense qu'il faut un contrôle accru
d'abord pour l'industrie du tourisme a
voulu évoquer la france est une grande
destination touristique dans le monde
donc si on fait un repli nationaliste
tel que le propose le front national ou
ou l'extrême gauche on voit bien que ce
n'est pas là ce n'est pas la réponse
parce que on a besoin aussi d'avoir des
estivants qui viennent en revanche ils
doivent être contrôlés ou au moment où
une grande année avec marc voulait
contrôler l'une des propositions que
nous nous avons fait c'est mon les
premiers contrôles de température de
destination de savoir où ils vont je
pense qu'il ya les moyens de mettre en
revanche ils sont trop de la température
refoule pas mais font l'objet d'un
examen supplémentaire pour s'assurer et
s'ils ont effectivement le coc vite
s'ils sont 600 contagieux il ya des
mesures d'isolement à prendre c'est à
des moyens vous savez faire ce pas vers
un dissuasif enfin c'est pas un moyen
dissuasif c'est un moyen de vérifier de
mettre le maximum de moyens de
protection à notre 10 alors revenons sur
le national est bien sûr la question de
l'école adrien juin à la clé en cas des
questions de contrôle puisque cette fois
dans le livre est préparée par les
députés à l'est républicain il y est
question du dépistage systématique des
professeurs des prises de température
pour les élèves ça vous paraît réaliste
faisable à quelle échelle
est ce qu'on va pouvoir de votre point
de vue à partir du mois de mai contre
les tous les professeurs et la
température de tous les élèves de france
est ce que ce sera le cas présent dans
votre commune
cauvin partir du moment où on allait les
masques et les tests on peut on peut le
faire c'est la regardons ce qui s'est
passé là aussi d'un des pays voisins
prenez l'exemple de l'allemagne tout à
l'heure l'allemagne a choisi une
stratégie différente de la nôtre avec
des tests non pas de manière générale
mais de manière beaucoup plus importante
de tester beaucoup plus de monde et de
diffuser beaucoup plus de distribuer
beaucoup plus de masquer la réalité
aujourd'hui c'est que sur un nombre de
malades à peu près équivalent on est à
en france à peu près à vingt mille décès
liés au co vide les allemands sont
autour de 5000 donc ce qui veut dire que
la logique mieux prix que la logique de
tester le maximum de gens et de protéger
au maximum moi je reprends la
proposition qui est fait par nos
éminents professeurs par philippe juvin
qui disent sur les républicains et
guerrier oui c'est une qualité
supplémentaire à qui il a dit carline en
plus doux à paris aussi on est des
compresses matin voilà mais qui dit
qu'un masque bien entendu il faut qu'il
soit bien évidemment de la meilleure
qualité qui soit de protection mais
quels qu'ils soient ils protègent
toujours et c'est mieux d'avoir un
masque de ne pas en avoir
mais donc vous dites que l'état fera
donc c'est du bon sens a failli si vous
faisiez je ne dis pas de l'état français
a failli je fais le constat aujourd'hui
on peut tous faire ensemble
vous avez les mêmes chiffres que moi la
réalité même nombre à peu près de
malades en allemagne qu'en france
à ce stade je dis avec toute la prudence
qui convient on est à peu près à 5000
décès identifiés liés aux qu'ovide nous
sommes à 20 mille enfants c'est un
constat mais ce n'est pas une critique
gratuite ces mois là mais si on était
donc c'est pour ça que je considère que
plus on peut tester
oui à partir du moment où des confidents
encore une fois on prend le risque est
que l'on doit assumer d'avoir une risque
de deuxième vague donc pour que cette
anticiper au mieux cette deuxième vague
il faut deux trois choses la première
chose à voir le plus généralisée au
maximum autant que possible le test de
gens qui sont en contact avec le public
deuxième élément généralisée là où on
peut
les plus meilleures conditions les
masses troisième élément réarmer
l'hôpital c'est essentiel c'est à dire
reconstituer les stocks alors que quand
nos adversaires media market devrait
revenir sur l'hôpital oui oui la roma il
viendra sur les tester sur les masquer
le problème c'est qu'on n'a pas assez
vous le savez françois bayrou au grand
jury la semaine dernière me disais moi
localement à pau nous avons commandé des
tests et des masques
est ce que vous avez fait la même chose
à provins roues et plus et lui me we
know if i may mais j'ai un excellent
maire à provins donc qui le fait qui
s'est préoccupée avec l'aide de la
région d'ailleurs la région ile de
france et est alors à partir il ya aussi
besoin d'une décision de l'éducation
nationale c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin
aussi d'avoir un cadre national qui soit
a soit fixé
si on n'a pas le cadre national pour le
fixer les professeurs sont pas obligés
de s'y soumettre et on a besoin de
l'état pour nous les fournir ça veut
dire qu'il pourrait avoir l'idée réactif
c'est à l'état de payer tout ça les
masques les tests pour ça qu'il va finir
6e y avoir un partage mais je pense que
il y à la nécessité d'une protection
qu'ils soient là la plus large possible
les collectivités territoriales ont fait
les avants sont nombreux à acheter
beaucoup aujourd'hui sur les tests
s'attarder beaucoup nous avons pris par
un arrêté municipal approuve à la
décision par exemple de tester les ehpad
nous l'avons fait dans les pattes public
bon il ya deux ehpad privé où je crois
que certains de ces en train de se
fermer
l'ehpad public vous demanderai au
gouvernement doit vous rembourser sur
toutes ces sommes investis localement ou
est-ce que vous vous estimez que c'est
de la responsabilité aussi de toute
façon à la fin des fins vous savez c'est
le contribuable qui paye a qu'une seule
poche
bon vent donc alors on viendra justement
sur les arômes et pour toujours à sur
l'école parce que c'est important est ce
que vous comprenez inquiétudes des
enseignants est ce que vous pensez aussi
vous comprenez lors que la possibilité
d'exercer un droit de retrait s'ils se
sentent pas en sécurité
écoutez sur le droit de retrait il est
prévu il est normal il est hors de
question de le remettre en cause
simplement il doit avoir un caractère
exceptionnel imaginez que nos
infirmières nous médecins nous aide
soignant et faire valoir leur droit de
retrait dans quelle situation sera
aujourd'hui
donc ça existe très bien mais ça doit
être dans un cadre très exceptionnel et
une dernière question peut-être sur
l'école ce sera sur la base du
volontariat ses terres que les parents
pourront choisir d'envoyer ou non leur
enfant à l'école ça vous paraît une
bonne décision
moi je suis très sceptique sur le jeu je
comprends je comprends bien l'idée du du
volontariat
ceci étant voyez à partir du moment où
on est dans le volontariat ça va vite
compliqué les choses et aussi pour les
collectivités raison d'ailleurs pour
laquelle on propose dans nos
propositions de ne pas réouvrir les
cantines
parce que comment vous faites pour
commander la cantine lorsqu'on est sur
la base du volontariat on a besoin de
paix loire meyer avait l'air à la vente
bah oui de commandes et donc et si on
rouvre pas les cantines on laisse ouvert
un sujet qui est l'inégalité sociale
devant le confinement qu'elle est une
épreuve facile gouvernement aujourd'hui
dire qu'aujourd'hui et des familles qui
ont du mal à nourrir leurs enfants à la
maison parce que la cantine ça coûte
quand même beaucoup moins cher souvent
oui on a aussi des allocations des
allocations familiales la responsabilité
d'un parent ans c'est d'abord de nourrir
ses enfants et et la politique familiale
est là pour ça c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons toujours défendu la
politique familiale ou moment le
gouvernement lui a porté des coups de
canifs d'ailleurs pas que celui ci celui
de françois hollande avant il connaît
donc après moi je vois pas c'est là
qu'on voit bien la difficulté c'est dire
on va ouvrir des cantines avec 200 ou
300 élèves qui vont qui vont déjeuner
ensemble dans une cantine et on va
fermer le restaurant qui sert 30
couverts bon tout ça me paraît alors
qu'il ya aussi la question des
transports vous êtes en ile de france
est assez majeur est ce qu'il faut
rendre le masque obligatoire dans les
transports en commun je pense que oui je
pense que oui parce que vous savez les
les gestes barrières et de distance dans
les transports quand et transports en
ile de france
marchât à 100% vous savez dans quelle
situation de confinement on est dans le
métro ou dans l'est ou dans les bus s'il
fonctionne comme je les ai entendus à
70% ça ça va être effectivement très
très très compliqué et vous la perdez
sur le comment vous l'appliquez au delà
des france parce que pour vous il faut
que le masque soit obligatoire dans tout
l'espace public tous les lieux où on est
susceptible de croiser des gens très
complet je pense dans les surfaces
commerciales importantes dans un certain
nombre d'endroits où il ya une densité
de population importante si vous
promener tout seul dans une dans une rue
et que vous croisez personnes bon au
siège de votre parti par exemple vous
allez demander le port du masque
obligatoire
écoutez pour le moment au travail et je
pense d'ailleurs ça va changer beaucoup
aller les choses on travaille uniquement
en visioconférence donc ça présente des
avantages vont enfin beaucoup
d'inconvénients 6 1
vous avez à suivre non mais je pense
qu'il y aura un avant et un après c'est
à dire qu'on a découvert qu'on pouvait
faire du télétravail
ah ça ne répond pas à tous et il ya
besoin de temps en temps d'avoir un
contact direct comme au grand jury mais
mais ceci étant je pense que les choses
vont évoluer et et on va découvrir
effectivement le télétravail on a
toujours été très réticent en france a
toujours eu beaucoup de mal et on
s'aperçoit que bon les gens travaillent
en fait beaucoup aussi de cette manière
là efficacement aussi reconnaissons
alors je disais en introduction cette
émission christian jacob que vous avez
et bien été victime du coronavirus a
révélé visiblement mieux aujourd'hui
vous nous confirmez la crise et le
dollar valait rien fait je le confirme
est ce que vous regrettez que le premier
tour des élections municipales où
beaucoup de gens disent avoir été
contaminées cement a été maintenue
écoutez sur les informations que l'on
avait faut toujours se remettre dans le
contexte de l'époque sur les
informations en avait qui étaient celles
que nous donner le premier ministre
puisque ces informations émanaient du
conseil scientifique et le premier
ministre et le président la république
avait l'exclusivité de ces informations
donc les informations qui nous ont été
données à ce moment là par le premier
ministre et par le président de la
république et par les différents
ministres c'est que rien ne s'opposait à
la tenue de ce premier tour c'est le
conseil scientifique qui le disaient à
condition que les gestes barrières
soient respectées et nous avions une
réunion avec tous les présidents de
partis politiques présidents des groupes
parlementaires de toutes les formations
et à la lumière de cette information
personne ne l'a contesté est ce que le
premier ministre nous l'a donnée ne
regrettez pas de ne pas avoir à l'époque
quand on regarde les choses à la lumière
de d'aujourd'hui effectivement on peut
se dire mais est ce qu'il n'ya pas eu
une erreur à ce moment là sauf que dans
le haut au moment où la décision est
prise
les informations qui nous sont données à
ce moment-là part entre le conseil
scientifique nous explique qu'il n'y a
pas de risque à condition de respecter
je serai derrière bonne foi pour vous
unir mans legré mante et de bonne foi
pour vous y abat il n'y a pas là vous
continuez à d'erreurs politiques non moi
je pense que le gouvernement était de
bonne foi je peux pas imaginer
d'ailleurs quillan qui leur seraient
autrement on va pas être dans ce type de
de suspicion les informations ont été
partagés avec toutes les formations
politiques personne n'a contesté ces
informations
et on n'y avaient pas accès mais je veux
dire il n'y a pas raison de contester
alors beaucoup d'élus les républicains
on sait que les élus locaux organisent
le vote beaucoup sont dans les bureaux
il ya beaucoup d'élus qui ont été
atteints par le coronavirus le jour du
premier tout à ça je peux pas vous dire
basta on sait jamais par définition
quand est-ce qu'on a été contagieux à
quel moment ce que je peux vous dire là
le seul chiffre que j'ai sur des hymnes
où les pour ce qu'il ya des des
parlementaires mais sans qu'ils aient eu
un cluster à l'assemblée nationale sur
notre groupe de députés ya à peu près 15
% des députés qui ont été touchés donc
ce qui est propulsé en lançant
importante mais il ya semble-t-il eu 1
kloster
au sein de au sein de l'assemblée j'aime
tous tiré d'affaires oui oui certains
ont été beaucoup plus moi je vais parler
de ce qu'il en sait pas été touché
heureusement mais certains collègues
l'ont été et il faire maintenant de ces
élections municipales quand faut-il les
organiser est ce que c'est au moins de
septembre
ou est-ce que vous pensez que ça peut
attendre les régionales de l'année
prochaine quelle est votre position qui
sont ils
d'abord il ya deux choses moi il ya une
demande que je faisais déjà faire
formulée à trois reprises au premier
ministre et je ne comprends pas que ce
ne soit pas mis en application
c'est d'abord d'installer les 30000 mer
il ya trente cinq mille communes en
france il ya trente mille conseils
municipaux qui ont été installés au
premier tour il est aux idées le premier
tour élu dès le premier tour par don élu
dès le premier tour dans un stade et il
faut les installer d'urgence parce qu'à
chaque fois que vous prenez du retard
pour installer ses conseils la lessive
aux sanitaires sont réunies de votre
point de vue et on le fait mais la
majorité des conseils municipaux ces 15
personnes
est ce qu'il ya une commune en france où
il n'y a pas la capacité de réunir 15
personnes et de les mettre à deux mètres
l'une de l'autre pour élire un conseil
municipal
quand vous allez à au supermarché il ya
plus de quinze personnes dans la salle
de ce supermarché dont il ya une urgence
absolue
pourquoi il ya cette urgence c'est
urgent ça n'a rien à voir avec la
politique
elle est purement économique à partir du
moment où les collectivités
territoriales ne peuvent pas délibérer
valablement on reporte la dépense là la
commande publique
et quand on voit que des secteurs comme
le bâtiment ou les travaux publics sont
très dépendants de la commande publique
chaque jour de retard qui est pris pour
installer ses 30000 conseils municipaux
ce sont des jours de retard pour la
lavande s'il arrive à compris des
menaces a échoué aller au bout je veux
aller au bout pour ceux qui n'entrent
est aisée mais je veux aller au bout
parce que ce sont des entreprises qu'on
est en train de fragiliser et des
milliers de chômeurs qu'on est en train
d'additionner parce qu'on prend du
retard pour installer ses 30000 mer il y
à une urgence absolue en allergie le
ritz sur le reste
moi je l' ai dit à plusieurs reprises et
redit au premier ministre dès que les
conditions sanitaires le permettent
il faut le faire dans les meilleurs
délais on aura le 23 mai ou plus tard un
rapport qui sera fait par le conseil
scientifique et à partir de la gauche de
racistes des cibles dans la foulée il
faut
les conditions sanitaires sont réunies
le faire si c'est possible en juin c'est
de loin préférable
parce que au delà de cela les au delà
des 30000 mer il ya les 5000 maires
supplémentaires et donc de cela va
dépendre les opci les intercommunalités
qui détiennent la compétence économique
donc là aussi sur la commande publique
c'est un enjeu déterminant si ça n'est
pas possible en juin il ya une
proposition de deux là mêmes qui me
semble tout à fait équilibrée qui est de
dire de le faire entrer dans
l'association des maires de france qui
est de le faire en septembre je pense
que c'est la bonne position d' équilibre
si on ne peut pas le ferrand en juin
l'idéal c'est le plus rapidement
possible mais si les conditions
sanitaires sont pas l'arbre faisons le
11 septembre et donc 6 septembre c'est à
dire vous passerez une partie de l'été
faire campagne dans les 5000 villes
restantes à huy cissé septembre décalera
d'autres d'autant mais ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est qu'on n'est pas
sûr un enjeu de politique politicienne
on est sur un enjeu éminemment
économique de cette décision vont
dépendre des milliers des milliers et
des milliers d'emplois alors je sais toi
la réalité n'arrive quasiment la mi
temps de cette élue mais cette émission
est ce que vous avez globalement
l'impression que le gouvernement fait ce
qu il faut qu emmanuel macron et son
premier thriller filles sont à la
hauteur la situation dans la gestion
économique de cette crise notamment le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'ils
m'ont il ya eu quand même une vraie une
vraie confusion sur les décisions les
kids id d'ailleurs on le sent vous les
uns les eaux dans les différents organes
de presse c'est ça ressort des tensions
entre l'elysée et matignon et entre
matignon et les ministres là par exemple
sur le déconfinement premier ministre
avait prévu de l'annoncé dans huit jours
mais il est doublé par certains de ses
ministres qui se précipitent pour
annoncer les mesures donc du coup ils
obligés d'anticiper le président de la
république qui dans le fonctionnement
normal de nos institutions fixent le cap
et ensuite le premier ministre met en
place la politique qui correspond à ce
cap
le président de la république va
intervenir à chaque fois dans les dom
avouer qu'en matière de diffusion fait
le bazar je dis pas que c'est le bazar
mais je dis que pour le moins il ya de
la confusion quand même et qui saute aux
yeux de tout le monde et la confusion
génère une moindre efficacité
c'est évident est ce que vous même vous
avez été consultés et associés à la
préparation tant que représentant d'une
force politique ces derniers jours ces
dernières semaines
absolument rien on a une réunion avec le
premier ministre qui est il d'ailleurs
je lui ai dit si tu es le premier
ministre d'avoir cette initiative mais
le premier ministre fait une déclaration
d'ouverture ensuite chaque président de
parti à quelques minutes pour donner son
avis et puis la réunion est terminée
c'est pour ça que vous voyez sur la
déclaration sur déconfinement ça peut
pas être une déclaration il faut qu'il
ya un débat qu'on travaille sur un texte
qu'on ait une proposition et et congrès
sera insuffisant le débat on line et au
moment de la loi de finances
rectificative
nous n'avons pas été dans l'opposition
systématique on a été force de
proposition et on a su à faire un moment
être capable de convaincre certains élus
de la majorité de se ranger à nos
propositions vous et seul bon travail
parle on y revient la deuxième partie de
l'émission notamment parlant du tracking
pour détecter les porteurs du
coronavirus a tout de suite après une
pause
[Musique]
si du grand jury rtl le figaro lci un
vide aujourd'hui le président des
républicains et député de seine-et-marne
christian jacob
le débat est dirigée par benjamin sport
tout ce qui vous pose
ils sont jacob la première question sa
seconde partie sur la chine et l' oms
qui sont toutes les deux pointés du
doigt depuis plusieurs semaines
d'ailleurs le vice président délégué de
votre parti guillaume pelletier estime
qu'elles ont toutes les deux anti otan
la chine qu'elle oms et ils proposent un
tribunal sanitaires internationales pour
juger à la chine est ce que ce sont des
propos pour partager des propositions
vous soutenez
c'est une proposition d'ailleurs
qu'avait fait déjà à guillaume pelletier
si j'ai bonne mémoire dans son dans son
livre dans son dernier livre et je vois
là je pense qu'il y à la nécessité de
faire la lumière absolue alors je ne
sais pas c'est la forme d'un tribunal en
tout cas là où je rejoins complètement
guillaume pelletier c'est qu'il faut
effectivement kim transparent il y à une
suspicion qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
supportable ils ont menti le msc la
chine de votre écoute et le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que les informations
étaient si on veut être prudent été pour
le moins évolutive entre les premières
déclarations en chine celle celles qui
s'en sont suivies après de quelle
manière
l' oms a pu contrôler ce qui avait été
dit par la chine ou pas on peut pas
rester dans l'incertitude il faut la
transparence et c'est ça la volonté de
guillaume pépy le président américain
qui est annoncé à quelques jours la
suspension de la contribution américaine
à l oms est ce que c'est une bonne
manière de procéder est ce que la france
devrait les suivre
je pense qu'on a besoin d'avoir une
organisation mondiale de la santé qui
soit qu'ils soient fortes et qu'ils
soient justement capable de travailler
en toute transparence dont il ya sans
doute des enseignements en tirer est
très vraisemblablement des
dysfonctionnements il faut faire la
lumière dessus mais c'est pas en coupant
en coupant les vivres qu'on va qu'on va
y répondre en revanche en étant beaucoup
plus exigeant et en regardant s'il ya eu
effectivement des responsabilités et
mensonges alors on revient sont la
france et une actualité de cette semaine
guillaume louis il ya depuis plusieurs
jours plus tôt depuis plusieurs nuits
des poussées de violence dans certaines
banlieues avec des attaques
de la police ces troubles sont limitées
dit le gouvernement à ce que vous
partagez ce constat écoutez ce qui nous
remontent et de du terrain c'est que
malheureusement je pense pas qu'il soit
limité et on voit bien que c'est sous
tension dans nos plus en plus de villes
eric ciotti chez nous qui suit ces
sujets de près me faisait part il ya
quelques jours de son inquiétude et des
remontées de terrain et des services de
de police effectivement il ya eu et ça
n'a jamais été pas la sécurité on peut
pas dire que c'était une priorité de ce
gouvernement du matin ne s'est pas vu et
donc on a vu tous les chiffres de la
délinquance augmente et de la
criminalité dans tous les secteurs et on
voit que dans cette période
eh bien il ya des tensions dans un
sourire contenu le pré le moment 10 et
contenu vous avez l'impression qu'ils
minimisent minor écoutez je n'ai pas le
sentiment que ce soit contenu du moins
les informations qui nous remontent font
plutôt penser au contraire qui est sous
la même façon que d'ailleurs sur un
autre sujet mais qui est lié à celui de
la sécurité sur les libérations
anticipées dans les prisons bon on a eu
dix mille libération de faiblesse ces
sujets de votre point de vue coûté dix
mille libération anticipée sur soixante
mille places en maisons si j'ai bien
compris on se prépare en fait à la fin
du confinement
on sera 10 milles supplémentaires et
pour aider renseigne et elle aura
personne qui arrivait en fin de peine
oui oui oui mais on a aussi
la justice qui à l'arrêt complet j'avoue
que j'ai un peu de difficulté à
comprendre pourquoi la justice à l'arrêt
complet la justice et aussi des moyens
des meilleurs dématérialisée avec
lesquels pourraient elles pourraient
travailler
donc je pense que dans ce domaine on a
un ministre de l'intérieur qui n'a pas
pris
à mon avis la mesure de la situation
explosive qu'il y avait dans un certain
nombre de quartiers et une ministre de
la justice qui a vite baissé les bras
sur le travail et l'efficacité qui
devrait être celle de son ministère
aujourd'hui je comprends pas pourquoi
toutes les juridictions sont à l'arrêt
ce je comprends qu'il ya besoin d'un
certain moment mais d'avoir
effectivement si vous allez au pouvoir
il y aurait pas eu libération de ces
10000 voter non mais parce que ce n'est
pas tant de savoir ce que vous feriez
vous oui mais à lire sur l'échappée
n'est pas dans la très importante n'est
pas dans ces conditions là effectivement
je pense qu'il faut être attentif il y
avait des mesures décidées sur des fins
de peine qui étaient les fans peines
courtes où on peut le comprendre mais
moi quand on me parle de chiffres de 20
milles sur soixante mille places en
prison je me dis quand même sa mère la
mère questions sur la sécurité est ce
que ça veut dire que vous voulez des
couvre-feux d'ici la fin du confinement
dans certaines villes de france c'est
sans votre vol et c'est parti
il faut laisser la possibilité aux
maires en lien avec les préfets encore
une fois on a le couple préfets et
maires qui doit fonctionner le maire
connaît sa ville connaissait quartier
c'est cette mesure est utile ou pas
s'agit pas de la generali vous ne
trouvez pas qu'un peu l'aide de la part
de certains élus locaux veulent
absolument faire plus dans ce genre de
situation et qui sont aussi en période
de d'élections municipales à venir
généralisée vous parlez de référence à
ma ville
un maire qui a été élu à plus de 60%
premier tour non mais dans certains cas
des parents ne sait pas encore le cas et
ça les bras le cas et on n'a pas vu du
tout de le faire à provins rien qui ne
justifie mais de dire que cet outil doit
être à disposition des maires en
fonction de la situation de leur ville
parce qu'ils la connaissent oui et c'est
encore une fois le couple préfets et
maires qui doit fonctionner autre
question des moquettes les syndicats de
police ont fait état d'une
d'instruction du responsable de la
police d'un départements le calvados de
ne pas intervenir dans les
rassemblements qui peuvent avoir lieu
avec la période du ramadan alors ensuite
au niveau national 7
cette information a été démentie c'est à
dire que il ya eu un contrôle mais
comment est-ce que vous réagissez à ce
type d'initiative je pense que si
c'était le cas c'est très inquiétant
alors bon ben ya eu comme vous dites
contre-ordre contre informations dont
ils sont bénéfice du doute mais enfin si
je pense que si cette information est
remonté des syndicats de policiers elle
ne vient pas de nulle part c'est que ça
a bien existé à un moment ou un autre
moi ce que je pense sur les cultes c'est
qu'à partir du moment où on s'engage
dans le déconfinement indien il faut
effectivement on le voit dans les les
deuils liés aux coronavirus mais deuil
d'une manière générale ne pas pouvoir
faire d'accompagnement religieux c'est
un traumatisme ce moment donc tant qu'on
est confiné on peut le comprendre
et si on va sur dd confinement il faut
se poser la question des offices
religieux et de pouvoir accompagner ses
défunts dans l'est les meilleurs le veut
dire qu'il faut sur izel et metz dès le
11 mai comme beaucoup de prêtres leur
réclame dans une tribune du figaro paris
hier
je pense que à partir du moment où des
conflits nés encore une fois si on
autorise des rassemblements doit pas y
avoir de régimes spécifiques
donc qu'est ce qu'on fait est ce qu'on
autorise balaiera on va le voir l'avion
volait à partir du 11 mai nous le
souhaitons qu'à voir la proposition qui
va être le gouvernement voit ce que je
pense c'est qu'à partir du moment où on
respecte les gestes barrières et qu'on
n'est pas sur des concentrations trop
importants de population et avec les
distances qui conviennent c'est à dire
des distances entre 1 et 2 mètres entre
chaque
entre chaque personne à mon avis il est
normal que les messes puisse reprendre
dans ces conditions-là de respect des
gestes voir les autres confessions
également oui bien sûr ça c'est une
question à rien je déconfinement l'un
des outils que le gouvernement pourrait
utiliser il nous le dira mardi c'est
cette application stop qu'ovide pour
faire du traçage via l'utilisation des
téléphones portables du bluetooth
est ce que vous y êtes favorable quelle
est la position des républicains sur
cette question
je suis extrêmement réservé sur cet opus
je pense que l'urgence aujourd'hui
objectivement c'est les masques les
tests et deux ont une foi de réarmer
notre notre héros est alors quoi parce
qu'on voit toutes les dérives qui peut y
avoir d'ailleurs l'avis de la cnil
même si la guinée et libertés
merci si elle habituellement c'est moi
qui reproche aux autres d'utiliser les
sigles mais vous avez raison
donc c'est notre commission nationale
des libertés si informatique et libertés
si elle reprend semences et certaines
propositions 10 ans est bien encadré
elle soulève tous les risques qu'il peut
y avoir
et le risque d'accoutumance et
d'utilisation à des fins que personne ne
soit on est en france dans un pays de
liberté et donc moi je suis très attaché
à cela donc faisons d'abord répondons
par les tests par les masques par les
mesures sanitaires de ton les hôpitaux
correctement et après on verra il y
avait rejoint doit de hangu dans votre
groupe sur ce bruit j'ai l'oeil mais
maintenant alors j'ai cru comprendre que
tout cela allait être y allait avoir une
déclaration commune
et là aussi il faut qu'ils aient un
texte on va pas voter sur un discours
ben vous aurez un vote d écouter je vous
ai dès mardi
je vous ai fait part de ma proposition
je souhaite qu'il y ait un travail
sérieux de l'assemblée et que les
parlementaires puissent s'exprimer on
peut d'ailleurs on pourrait même
imaginer qu'ils aient des votes à
distance vers ce n'est pas non plus
quelque chose de remplaçante 15 députés
voilà dans les 1007 pas alors on en
viendrait semblables sur un sujet comme
on engage des 577 députés puissent voter
a donc vous voulez que ce face à face à
des geeks et ça mérite par par
visioconférence non non mais on peut
très bien imaginer un conte est un vrai
travail en commissions oui le mans je
souhaite que l'on puisse débattre faire
des propositions cette reprise le cas le
cas échéant et ensuite sur un sujet
comme celui là je trouve dommage qu'on
voit est à 75 députés
on en vient à la l'issue de la crise les
solutions que vous l'ayez à porter et
notamment parce que c'est vrai que dans
votre groupe est bien des propositions
qui viennent un peu de partout ça
foisonne alors peut-être que vous allez
me dire vous ce que vous en pensez par
exemple de bruno retailleau qui
demandent donc on
c'est de travailler jusqu'à 37 heures
par semaine ça fait 1700 heures à
l'année avec un quota d'heures
supplémentaires car de 300 heures est ce
qu'il faut augmenter le travail durée de
travail momentanément sur une année pour
compenser les pertes dues à cette crise
sanitaire qui sans jacques rogge d'abord
ce n'est pas une proposition de bruno
retailleau c'est un sujet qu'on a
longtemps débattu alors et eddie house à
2 les républicains je pense que il y as
besoin de sortir du carcan des 35 heures
en revanche si on travaille davantage on
doit être payé davantage
donc vous êtes d'accord c'est évidemment
payer 3 et elle pense que pendant il
faut laisser la liberté nous l'avons
évoqué au moment du débat sur la loi sur
le travail en disant qu'il fallait
laisser la liberté au sein de
l'entreprise dans un cadre défini qui
est celui là la limite des 40 heures de
pouvoir donner la possibilité de
travailler 37 38 39 40 heures à
condition bien entendu que tout ces gens
soient payés et ça ça permet à la fois
d'augmenter le pouvoir d'achat des
salariés de manière significative et en
même temps de redonner de la
compétitivité aux entreprises parce que
ça permet de baisser le coût donc si un
des éléments qui ressort de cette crise
c'est notre dépendance aux puissances
étrangères sur la santé on l'a vu avec
la chine ou même sur l'alimentaire est
aussi un sujet très très important ou la
la france et l'union européenne doivent
retrouver leur leur autonomie il faut
gagner des points par les coûts
directement cette question en plus qui
vous est agressé par un syndicaliste
cftc
c'est la question et rougerie
question on plisse joseph thouvenel
secrétaire confédéral cftc la
confédération française des travailleurs
chrétiens
monsieur jacob bonjour certains
voudraient remettre en cause aujourd'hui
la durée du travail dans les pays hors
vous savez qu aucun texte n'interdit un
chef d'entreprise de faire travailler
ses salariés au delà de 35 heures le
fond du problème n'est-il pas dans cette
compétition internationale le fait que
nous subissons de plein fouet
concurrence déloyale notamment de la
chine en matière fiscale en matière
environnementale et en matière sociale
et tant que nous n'aurons pas le courage
de régler ce problème de cette
concurrence déloyale
nous n'y arriverons pas merci d'écrire
là christian jacob la question n'est pas
la durée du travail mais la concurrence
des autres pays dont la chine mais
l'armée les jeux je partage complètement
cette annexe des répondants deux points
sur la durée du temps de travail
moi je pense qu'il faut sortir du carcan
des 35 heures le faire encore une fois
dans le cadre de l'entreprise et autour
d'un consensus social
là où les entreprises sont de trop
petite taille on peut le faire par
branche
mais il faut sortir de ce sommet jusqu'à
deux mois près combien crise en jacques
soignants sont précis est ce que ces 37
heures ce que c'est trop nous sommes
aimés vais je voulais le maxi mais
peut-être n'avez-vous pas été attentif
j'ai dit on peut être dans la limite des
40 heures 40
mais le débat au sein autour d'un
consensus social dans l'entreprise ou
dans la branche
et c'est comme ça qu'on est bien entendu
des heures payées ensuite la la question
de la compétitivité est essentielle et
c'est là qu'on a besoin d'une europe
politique beaucoup plus forte qu'elle ne
l'est aujourd'hui sur les normes
sociales sanitaires et environnementales
pourquoi je me suis opposé pourquoi
notre groupe parlementaire
nos deux groupes parlementaires de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat se
sont posés aux accords du ceta par
exemple eh bien c'est parce que on
existe on accepte cet accord de
libre-échange avec le canada
on accepte des importations de pays qui
ne respecte pas les mêmes normes que
nous par exemple sur la viande bovine
les les canadiens etc
liberté autorise la possibilité
d'utiliser des hormones de croissance ou
des farines issues d'animaux pour
nourrir leurs bovins nous depuis 94
c'est interdit en france
donc on a des règles là deux
concurrentes qui sont totalement
déloyale et donc on doit absolument
imposer ces normes sociales sanitaires
environnementales dans les accords de
libre échange et c'est ça la compétition
saine et pour ça il nous faut une europe
politique beaucoup plus fort avec nos
gens répond c'est pas un petit mot
encore du temps de travail parce que
c'est très important dans les
propositions faites par les républicains
en l'occurrence par le numéro de
guillaume pelletier est aussi l'idée de
supprimer cinq jours de rtt en
augmentant les salaires afin de financer
la santé et l'agriculture dans cette
phase va s'ouvrir de reconstruction
économique
est-ce qu'on peut à ce point de demander
un effort aux français qui serait de
supprimer encore cinq jours de repos
tout cela se ces propositions se
rejoignent et sont les mêmes sont celles
de redonner de la souplesse encore une
fois est au travail et plus autour d'un
consensus social en contre ça peut pas
se faire ça ne se décrète pas c'est dans
le cadre de l'entreprise en fonction
aussi du carnet de commandes de
l'entreprise
parce que il y a des moments où
l'entreprise à des marchés et des
moments elle n'en a pas et donc ça c'est
ça le vrai dialogue social dans
l'entreprise et c'est vraiment là dessus
qu'il faut qu'on évolue et arrêter de
penser que c'est l'état qui va décider
de tout sur ces sujets laissons les
entreprises et les salariés au sein de
ces entreprises de trouver les bons
moyens de consensus de rémunération et
de temps de travail en le global is an
mais dans la composition que vous faites
il ya aussi des mesures qui dépendent de
l'état
j'ai noté l'annulation des charges
fiscales et sociales le temps du
confinement la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires
est-ce que vous avez chiffré ce que
coûterait toutes ces mesures de relance
alors sur la mesure d'annulation il
semble que le gouvernement je crois les
repris phrase ou pas eu la confirmation
mais plusieurs informations qui me dit
que le disent que le gouvernement le
rapport oui mais je crois que justement
ils ont évolué parce que moi j'étais 20
ans chef d'entreprise j'ai aussi été
ministre des pme
et je sais que sur la vie d'une
entreprise le défaut de trésorerie peut
être très vite catastrophique et donc il
y as intérêt à redonner de l'oxygène
tout de suite parce que si jamais vous
avez un premier défaut de paiement après
vous avez l'urssaf les impôts et ses
terres à tous qui se mr en vrille et
donc c'est la chute inexorable
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut aller à
mon avis vers de l'annulation sur le
temps où il n'y a pas de où il n'y a pas
d'activité où il ya eu d'ailleurs des
fermetures des fermetures
administratives donc ça c'est une mesure
qui me semble très très importante et le
deuxième élément de votre question était
la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires sur la défiscalisation
ça aussi c'est une mesure sociale et
fiscale
il faut faire les deux leviers quoi
qu'il en coûte oui mais oui mais parce
que encore une fois on a besoin de
redonner pour relancer la machine
économique
il faut redonner de la compétitivité aux
entreprises qui est large accord commun
sur le court mais pose est ce que l'on
estime aujourd'hui c'est que c'est un
chiffre sur lequel il semble que tout le
monde s'accordent c'est qu'il y a eu à
peu près 60 60 milliards d'euros qui
n'ont pas été dépensés dans l'économie
avec le temps du confinement donc et
sait pas quand on va d confiné que ces
60 milliards vont revenir sur le marché
vous n'allez pas aller au restaurant
quatre fois par jour donc on voit bien
qu'il ya là une épargne d'où une des des
propositions est intéressant et nash
français christophe l'argent c'est à
dire vous avez par le confinement
vous avez des dépenses qui n'ont pas été
occasionné des recettes il a échappé
votre voiture pour aller travailler
de freige intérieur et c'est donc le
livret c'est derrick bird ou voilà une
proposition très intéressante qui est
celle d'eric woerth avec l'idée du livre
et c'est qui c'est comme comco vide qui
pourrait permettre de créer un fond des
temps qui viendraient en aide aux pme
notamment mais bon pme tpe tout à toutes
les entreprises
eric woerth l'a conçu sur une logique
d'investissement en disant on doit pas
ne doit pas intervenir bientôt sur la
dépense de fonctionnement mais sur de
l'investissement donc et créateurs
d'activité
plouard eric woerth qui a aussi beaucoup
d'idées et qui est très attaché à la
rigueur sur les déficits publics
vous dites dans vos propositions il faut
un moratoire d'un an sur les impôts et
après est ce que on pourra me sera
obligé d'augmenter la pression fiscale
pour compenser le manque à gagner que
l'on vient de connaître
moi je pense que vraiment il ne faut pas
avoir recours à l'impôt encore une fois
si la dépense publique était un gage
d'efficacité la france serait championne
du monde
on est les champions du monde des
prélèvements obligatoires et fiscaux
arrêtons met donc correspondre à la
dette dont vous voulez ça passera alors
il ya deux choses il ya à la fois un
travail sur la dépense publique je dire
faut pas s'exonérer de ce travail sur la
dépense publique mais on sait aussi
qu'on a besoin d'amortisseurs sociaux
d'ailleurs on l'a bien vu l'amusé lors
d'une audience publique où les mots ne
me les murs pernes et comment vous
proposer plutôt des dépenses publiques
supplémentaires dans les infos
rganisation des heures sup web parce que
d'annulations de charles si l'entreprise
tombe ça coûte beaucoup plus cher vous
voulez mais les économies ailleurs une
entreprise qui fait faillite
les conséquences sont beaucoup plus
chers et sont plus chers sur le plan
social
parce qu'il faut prendre tout le
personnel qui se retrouvent au chômage
et les aides etc
c'est au pire que tout donc il ya une
idée qui avait été évoqué dans les
colonnes d'un excellent journal que
guillaume roquette connaît bien sûr une
proposition de françois par mois sur la
monétisation de la dette et c'est une ré
1 s'était proposée par françois baroin
on en train de travailler sur cette sur
cette idée qui permettrait effectivement
d'éviter d'être bloqués dans les deux
mâchoires sercel de dire on va mettre
plus d'un mot on va supprimer les
amortisseurs sociaux
moi je pense que la dépense publique
mérite et encore une fois je salue le
travail d'eric woerth mais aussi tous
nos deux députés les républicains là
dessus sur la dépense publique
mais n'allons pas sûr de l'impôt c'est
l'heure de questions express sourire
question expressistes ans jacob pour ou
contre l'association temporaire d'air
france je suis là où sion réservé de
manière générale l'état différentes
manières de pouvoir intervenir
ça n'est pas automatiquement par la
nationalisation mais il peut intervenir
dans le capital comme celui là
aujourd'hui
voilà kourouma une nationalisation en
effet clos contre l'abandon de la
réforme des retraites telle qu'elle a
été présentée oui cette réforme n'avait
ni queue ni tête personne n'y comprenait
rien je pense qu'il faut vraiment
remettre ce travail a placé trois ans
pour rien pour ou contre l'abandon de la
réforme des allocations chômage je pense
qu'il faut stopper faut conserver les
uns les amortisseurs sociaux tels qu'ils
sont aujourd'hui
ils viennent de montrer leur efficacité
pour ou contre une équipe de
personnalités politiques transcourants
pour diriger la france
après la crise on n'a pas besoin de
ministres en plus on a besoin d'avoir un
travail sérieux sévère d'une majorité
qui est capable d'écouter son opposition
de travailler sérieusement avec et nous
la démonstration du travail sérieux je
crois que nous l'avons nous l'avons fait
avec encore une fois beaucoup de sérieux
beaucoup d'efficacité aussi nouveau
contre enfin françois baroin candidats
en 2022 était la réponse viendra ce
moment-là vous connaissez et mon
attachement il soutient que je lui
apporte les ça n'est pas le suivre on
l'entend peu guillaume roquette un
disque en ce moment c'est pourtant le
patron des maires de france
oui ecoutez-le étais j'ai vu un papier
dans vos colonnes hier si j'ai bonne
mémoire il avait enlevé sa parole porte
et fait plus confiance seuls les pas
d'un naturel timide donc parlera bientôt
il parlera lorsque le moment sera et
saint-laurent galata haut
il a l'air plus dans le décapant de
l'état il a il est capable de parler sur
beaucoup d'autres sujets notamment
excuse ans a récemment servi que les
récentes et plus fort des dauphins
responsabilités de président de
l'association des maires de france où il
a un rôle éminent et on le voit à chaque
congrès chaque année mais aussi le fait
que c'est un acteur du quotidien dans sa
ville de troyes est-ce que vous avez
l'impression est bien que l'apport la
présence et 2022 il y pense davantage
aujourd'hui au regard des événements je
veux pas me substituer au grand jury
dont vous lui poserez vous maintenant on
l'accueillera quand ils me françois
baroin on me lance l'invitation à
nouveau celle hors de question net
grand jury puisse tout mais bonjour
maroc à rabat bonjour à tous bonjour
christian jacob
alors les internautes découvrent ce
matin une vidéo où l'on voit une
vingtaine de personnes dansaient dans
les rues de paris ça se passe dans le
18e arrondissement il ya des badauds qui
les regarde assez bailly tout ça a
provoqué un attroupement ensuite la
police est intervenue pour les
verbaliser
on sent qu'il ya un relâchement à deux
semaines du début du déconfinement
est-ce que d'après vous il faut durcir
les sanctions
je pense pas qu'ils aient besoin de
besoin de durcir les sanctions
en revanche il y a 2 juin que le
confinement soit respectée on a vu
l'efficacité du du confinement et on a
tous vraiment une responsabilité
collective tiers de rester chez nous et
de respecter jusqu'à ses instructions
qui nous sont donnés jusqu'au bout autre
question oui alors le professeur didier
raoult l'edt sans être nommés et
s'attirer les foudres de l'ordre des
médecins qui le menace à mots couverts
de le suspendre à cause des protocoles
de recherche clinique illégaux est ce
que pour vous l'ordre des médecins
pendant le conseil de l'ordre des
médecins est dans son rôle
d'abord je suis ni médecin et encore
moins au conseil de l'ordre donc me
demandez pas de me substituer une
décision de conseils de gens ça provoque
un débat au sein des déchets c'est un
débat qui relève le conseil de l'ordre
vous avez pris la chloroquine vous pas
christian jacob
non alors comment et comment vous
percevez se débat dans votre crise 3 y
en a pris forme en mai mois les loyers
sont devenus les plus grands défenseurs
cuisant grande avocate du professeur
raoul temps moi j'aime ça qu'ils
achètent j'applique une règle simple
c'est quand je suis malade je fais
confiance à mon médecin et jusque
maintenant ça plutôt bien marché mais
ils sont allés trop loin parce que mon
est évident assure l'armée mais nous les
dépenses jamais voir où j'en étais et je
fais confiance à mon médecin et je pense
que me prescrit mon médecin et encore
une fois jusque maintenant basse on a
plutôt réussi donc plutôt envie de
continuer donc voilà je peux pas me
substituer des débats qui sont pas
je le côtoie je suis pas médecin la
foudre est un genre on a appris cette
semaine que l'armée avait constitué des
stocks de chloroquine jérôme salomon le
directeur général de la santé a refusé
cette semaine de commenter ce que vous
vous considérez que l'armée dans son
rôle en constituant des stocks d'un
médicament dont on ne sait même pas s'il
sera efficace pour lutter contre cette
maladie
là aussi il y à alarmer suffisamment de
médecins et de professeurs de médecine
pour savoir s'il y a effectivement un
intérêt à le faire ou pas mais de nous
demander une politique d'aller bientôt
prescrire je vais pas vous prescrire ce
qu'il faut que vous preniez si vous avez
la grippe ou si vous avez telle ou telle
maladie
je n'en sais rien ce n'est pas mon
métier et que chacun règne dans le cadre
qui est le sien vous êtes beaucoup plus
prudent que certains des votes
on le remarque aujourd'hui mais certains
de rien sont six médecins ce que j'avais
reçus baissant qui se sont exprimés pour
un coût nul et non je crois connaître et
pense à mon ami renaud muselier il y
avait un don qui ont été relogés soit
très allants sur cette question
marie-pierre haddad
oui alors il ya aussi une autre vidéo
qui a beaucoup fait parler sur twitter
où on voit des longues files d'attentes
de voitures devant les restaurants mal
de mcdonald's donc certains internautes
sont un peu tombés des nues en voyant
cette réaction il ya eu aussi beaucoup
de moqueries sur les réseaux sociaux
est ce que pour vous quand vous avez vu
ces images vous ai dit c'est la vie qui
reprend ou au contraire vous à dire rien
ne va changer avec cette crise du corner
virus j'ai passé sur quoi voulez me
faire réagir
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé quand vous
avez vous eu des bouchons dans la ville
à cause de la réouverture des drive de
mcdonald's et je suis pas voilà ça vous
laisse vous inquiétez pas ce n'est pas
une critique mais ne suis pas un habitué
de ce type de restaurants nos sociétés
en nom de marche bien aussi à province
mais voilà je pars pas d'avis
particulier
moi je reste sur un raisonnement qui est
simple c'est celui où il faut rester
chez soi je fais partie comme tous les
français parfait essaye de sortir le
moins possible et donc de rester
rapidement parce qu'on parle de produits
de consommation alimentaire une secrète
un général de votre parti aurélien
pradié propose de bloquer les prix de
cent produits alimentaires ça nous
rappelle
les années mitterrand ont cessé à gauche
tout les républicains pour j'aime
beaucoup aurélia mais sur cette mesure
c'est pas le blocage des prix et
alimentait c'est un paysan qui vous le
dis je ne pense pas que ce soit une
bonne en revanche c'est mais je pense
que c'est à sa qu'aurélien fait rio la
fin c'est le parfois les marges que sont
faits par certains réseaux de
distribution bien fonctionnement non
remplacement les réseaus 10 ans du mac
jorion est normal est pas d'accord avec
eux
[Musique]